we know that insidious's key faced demon
has been around haunting the cell blocks
of duben State Penitentiary since at
least 1953 but it's likely that his
history goes back much deeper than that
as a child psychic medium Elise Rainier
encountered spirits of many who had died
in the prison but stuck around to haunt
the place on the ground surrounding it
there's so many spirits in this house
it's hard to tell the good from the evil
a lot of people died in that prison part
of the reason there are so many spirits
has to do with the execution side being
located on property dewbound is most
likely a stand-in for a real prison
Penitentiary of New Mexico which opened
in 1885 and contained a now defunct gas
chamber for executions which along with
other incidents gave the place a
reputation of being haunted so it's
likely that this is around the time key
face first started showing up the late
1800s to learn why this evil creature
came to develop this terrifying look
where he fits into the hierarchy of
Insidious entities and what this
character truly represents stick around
to the end of this video this video is
sponsored by Factor
[Music]
welcome to Horror history I'm going to
need everyone to turn around please and
put your hands on the wall now where did
I put that whipping stick in today's
video I am analyzing the antagonist of
Insidious the last key which is the
fourth chapter of the Insidious
franchise they call him Ki face which
doesn't really make sense to me clearly
the keys are on his fingers not his face
maybe they were trying to name this
character in such a way that it would
remind people of red face the poster boy
of Insidious antagonists or maybe it has
something to do with this early piece of
concept art where the skin around his
nose and mouth is absent forming a kind
of lock shape but that does come with
its own question why wouldn't they just
call him block face but etymology aside
he face was played by Javier botet who
was known for his roles as lanky
disjointed horror creatures like the
leper and it the Crooked Man in The
Conjuring 2 and the big toe monster in
scary stories to tell in the dark all of
which are side villains so it's nice to
finally get to talk about one of his
roles as the main bad guy but to fully
understand why this demon haunted and
Disturbed the ghost hunting hero Elise
Rainier more than any other we've got to
take it back to his earliest victims at
the do Bend penitentiary
thank you
foreign
like other Demons of Insidious lore
takes on an appearance to appeal to
those that he's trying to capture I've
previously analyzed other entities and
discussed how their form factor is meant
to lure their victims into the further
Insidious director James Wan stated that
the red-faced demon was originally meant
to lure curious children in with his
bright colors and almost carnival-esque
appearance the man who can't breathe
from insidious chapter 3 appeared as a
sickly man in order to Garner sympathy
from victims and remind them of someone
they know who had suffered which is why
Quinn Brenner lets her guard down around
the demon after losing her mouth
keface's victims are all prisoners at
the penitentiary his goal is to drag
them into an even worse kind of
captivity in the confines of the
Purgatory realm known as the further he
appeals to them with his appearance by
taking a form that teases the promise of
Freedom with his keys for fingers he
almost looks like he could be a
mischievous Spirit who could let the
prisoners out he also has long uncamped
hair a clear sign that he could be on
their side as opposed to the prison
staff who have strict requirements to
maintain short neatly groomed hairstyles
keface was first granted access to the
real world in September of 1953 when
Elise Rainier daughter of the prison's
assistant Warden Gerald Rainier is
locked in the basement as punch for
using her psychic abilities to
communicate with one of the many ghosts
on the property keyface uses a childlike
voice to get her attention and shines a
light through the keyhole of the door in
the basement to try to quell her fear
each demonic entity in the further
resides behind a red door but since
Elise is a medium she can see the door
in the real world just as she can often
see spirits in her world Ki face uses
the voice to tell her to open this door
with a key hanging on the wall and
explains that she's the only one that
can help open all the doors this is
because elise's father and brother
clearly don't have the same ability that
she does and her mom if she possesses
any psychic ability is afraid to use it
and probably mature enough to know
better than to help a strange voice
however when Elise unlocks the door it
spits out the key which now takes on a
fleshy appearance Elise watches in
horror as keface reaches out and the key
reattaches itself as one of his fingers
we see Sparks as keyface touches the
doorknob which I'll explain in a little
bit his Newfound access to the real
world also allows Elise to enter the
further for the first time causing her
eyes to roll back in her head as the
entire house shakes when her mother
comes down to respond to the commotion
she finds Elise convulsing and
hyperventilating in the corner and
keface influences a loose wire to wrap
around her neck and hangs her where she
stands I don't know if Mrs Rainier had
the same abilities as Elise but if she
did I can see why Ki face wanted to get
rid of her first her death causes the
already abusive father and Gerald to
become even worse which is exactly what
keface wants because he literally
thrives off of it fear and pain is what
feeds them over the next eight years he
would use that fear and pain to control
Gerald's actions God he doesn't mean it
when he yells at me
cared of the man with the keys
he's the one controlling it all he's the
one who opens all the doors in insidious
chapter 3 Elise explains that there are
two types of demons those who want to
possess the bodies of the living like
redface and those who just want the
souls of the living to join it in the
shadows like the man who can breathe
based on the fact that kephase operates
out of a prison block and aims to
capture as many people as possible he
seems to fall into the second category
he face excels at controlling their
actions using their fear of him to make
them do what he wants after Elise lets
him into the world of the living He
forces elise's father to become a
kidnapper and he secretly takes several
women as prisoners and the extra room in
his basement after killing them they
become permanent prisoners when keface
traps their souls in the further so
there are many layers at play here
Gerald works out of prison keeps
prisoners at home and is a prisoner of
the Demon's control overhead later the
suitcases of the women he kidnapped or
discovered in an air duct in the
basement the sixth and presumably final
victim was a waitress named Anna in the
early 1960s she used a loose nail to
escape from the room she was captive in
and made it upstairs where she came face
to face with a now teenage Elise only
problem was Elise was so used to seeing
ghosts and Anna dirty pale and
malnourished from her time in captivity
kind of looks a bit ghastly like me
after a long editing session because of
this Mr Rainier was able to Gaslight his
daughter into thinking that Anna was
just another ghost and this leads to a
fight where Elise runs away from home
this allows Gerald to go back and kill
Anna without being discovered I'm not
sure what elise's brother Christian was
doing at the time but it's possible that
he was distracted by his distress over
his sister abandoning the family at some
point when he was old enough Christian
got out himself and with nobody left to
torture keface took Gerald's life and he
became a ghost in the further
historically the ghost of the further
tend to maintain the appearance of the
age that they died at and Gerald's ghost
looks to be about 15 to 20 years older
than he was in 1953 so we can assume
that keface killed him in the 1960s or
1970s and took his ghost as one of his
Prisoners the house sat vacant for about
40 years until a single man named Ted
Garza dumped his life savings into
buying the house which turned out to be
as poor of a personal choice as it was a
poor real estate investment as he became
the next to be haunted by the demon
known as Ki face
fans of my channel know I love getting
my meals from Factor because of how much
time it saves me but just how much time
is that let's break it down choosing a
meal whether that's browsing delivery
apps or looking for recipes it ends up
being about 10 minutes of comparing
options going to the store and buying
ingredients is probably a 30 minute trip
for me but I usually order my groceries
online so let's just call this 15
minutes preparing the meal this is
obviously going to vary from recipe to
recipe but between cutting portioning
and preheating this is usually another
10 minutes and that's being generous
cooking the meal again this will
probably depend on what you make but
I'll be generous again and say that a
really quick meal takes like 25 minutes
and let's not forget when you're making
your own meal you have to do the dishes
and clean up that's another 10 minutes
at least add it all up and that's 65
minutes on a good day Factor takes two
you put it in the microwave you press
two and you're all set which means you
can save at least 63 minutes a day by
using factor factor also offers Gourmet
plus meals as part of your weekly
options whenever you're craving
something special I'm always impressed
with how they never taste dry or tough
after a trip through the microwave
factor is now owned by hellofresh so
cz's World viewers can enjoy both brands
with my discount to get started with
Factor go to factor75.com click the link
below and use code cz50 to get 50 off
your first Factor box that's
factor75.com and use code cz50 for 50
percent off
[Music]
after making contact with the House's
newest inhabitant Ted Garza he face
forces him to kidnap a nurse from nearby
and lock her in the basement for four
months continuing the cycle of abduction
that he started with Gerald I think it
made Ted Garza do what he did but unlike
Gerald Ted seems slightly more resistant
and tries to take action to get rid of
the disturbance from his home eventually
in 2010 he considers calling elise's
company spectral sightings to
investigate which really shows how
desperate he must have been bringing in
Ghost Hunters would make it pretty
likely that his prisoner would be
discovered then again if keface was
controlling him maybe that's what he
wanted to happen maybe bringing Elise
back into the fold was part of the plan
for KI face to finally imprison The One
That Got Away but in the 40-something
years since elise's departure she's
buried a lot of her old memories due to
the trauma that she experienced from her
father she's essentially forgotten about
Ki face in her Elder years but as keface
takes a stronger and stronger hold on
Ted Garza Elise begins having nightmares
about key face again and sketches him
inside of her book of seeing these
nightmares consist of scenes from her
childhood and as these memories slowly
come back she fills in more of the
picture after one nightmare about her
childhood she writes down give me the
key the dreams are coming back Warren
just walk away will it screenwriter Lee
wanal expanded on how he created the
demon as a manifestation for what Elise
is going through
the demon really represents the trauma
that has affected Elise her whole life
and this demon who has keys for fingers
has the power to lock and unlock these
doors into elise's past I think if we
read between the lines here key face is
not just literally unlocking these
portals in the further but the keys
represent him unlocking memories that
bring back up the trauma in Psychology
this is known as triggering a stimulus
that causes a painful memory to
resurface it could be a sound sight
smell any other sensory experience or
even another memory the reason for this
is because the brain is a literal neural
network so as one part of the brain gets
fired up it'll also activate the neurons
connected to that part neurophysicist
Donald tab used the term neurons that
fire together wire together the concept
is often seen in children who have
suffered abuse oftentimes any physical
contact good or bad will trigger a fight
or flight response because it triggers
memories of the abuse at the beginning
Elise doesn't seem to fully remember
everything that went down but the trauma
comes back to her through her dreams and
eventually through revisiting her
childhood home a trauma victim might
even refer to this process as unlocking
old memories much like how you might
unlock memories in a video game the
first night at the old house at least
stays in her old room where most of the
supernatural activity is focused and a
ghostly figure sneaks up on her but when
she turns she sees her dad's old uniform
I believe that this was key face because
when she goes to touch the set of keys
on the jacket pocket she gets a little
static shot just like what we saw when
keface touched the doorknob in her
childhood there are also other examples
of keyface having a shock to the touch
going forward like his other attributes
I think there's symbolism here as well
static electricity can be built up when
materials rub together causing electrons
to build up in an object when you touch
that object you may get a static shot
you can't see the electrons when they're
built up on the surface but they are
there waiting to be accessed it's a lot
like how Elise represses her painful
childhood memories but when she revisits
the house and comes across Ki face the
memories rush back and she's in for a
painful shot eventually Anna's ghost
helps at least discover Garza's human
prisoner and save her while she's still
alive when Garza retaliates one of
elise's employees spax is forced to trap
him under a bookcase which ultimately
ends up killing him keyface needs a new
Target and finds one when to Lisa's
nieces no rhyme intended Melissa and
Imogen visit the house to help Christian
search for a whistle given to him by his
mom before she died Melissa searches the
basement and finds several rings of keys
but after seeing one of them move on
their own discovers that they're
actually connected to the hand of a
demon who easily slaps her across the
room drawing blood then from another
part of the basement he crawls toward
her and sticks the key extending from
his index finger into her throat
allowing him to lock her vocal cords
effectively putting her on mute then he
inserts another key into her chest and
locks her heart as well which
effectively puts her into a coma in the
real world and imprisons her spirits in
the further it ties back to this sign
seen when Elise and Company first arrive
at her hometown in New Mexico it says
welcome to five Keys we'll unlock your
heart that's exactly what they'd have to
do to save Melissa by what I assume is a
crazy coincidence the actress that plays
Melissa is named Spencer lock or maybe
there was some subconscious Association
going on during the casting process
anyway she's transferred to the hospital
so Elise and Tucker continue to
investigate and find the air duct
containing the suitcases of all the
abducted woman only one of them contain
in some extra baggage
this drags Elise into the further where
she sees more scenes of her past and
risks paradoxy by speaking to her
younger self encouraging her to never be
afraid of her ability Ki face doesn't
like the two elise's Coke inspiring
however and attacks the older version
from behind before putting her in a cage
which is in a jail cell kind of
redundant she's one of many prisoners
stretching back as far as the eye can
see this means Ki face likely has more
prisoners in the dark than the man who
can't breathe than red face combined
each cell is themed to an area relevant
to that person elise's is her childhood
room where she was abused her father's
cell is the room with the TV where he
spent all of his free time keface
unlocks their cells but instead of
attacking them himself he simply hands
Elise her dad's old cane hoping to see
elise's anger overcome her and get
revenge on her abusive dad remember fear
and pain is what feeds him which makes
him more of a psychological horror than
his red and blue counterparts Insidious
the last key director Adam robitel
touched on this a little bit in an
interview with collider I really felt
like if you're gonna make a movie about
elise's origin story she's sort of like
a superhero she's not really afraid of
ghosts so you need something that really
really scares how do you do that well
you play into her psychology you play on
the thing that she hates the most which
is this relationship with her father At
first she falls for it and repeatedly
whacks him with the cane just as he once
did to her and we see the effect in real
time it seems to Exhilarate key face and
maybe even give him some power as Elise
beats down Gerald there's a quick
intercut shot of Gerald in turn abusing
Anna the captured woman in the 1960s the
further is a realm capable of connecting
different points in time so it seems to
suggest that keyphase is simply using
elise's rage and channeling it to her
father that raises the question of how
time travel Works in this universe it
seems to be the Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban model where those
who travel back in time have always
traveled back in time this means that
they can't change their Destiny there
are infinite versions of Elise scattered
through different points in time and
they will all follow the same path even
when our release was a child she still
spoke to the older Elise in the further
even though that had not happened yet it
seems to be that she forgets about this
encounter over the years allowing it to
happen at this point in time over and
over again we saw something similar
happen in Insidious Chapter 2 when Josh
Lambert was the one who set off the
burglar alarm in his house during the
events of the first incities the result
of this is the Dark Truth that elise's
inability to control her rage resulted
in the death of the waitress Anna in the
past and there's nothing she can do to
change her Destiny however she soon
realizes that her hatred is feeding the
demon setting up a confrontation 57
years in the making
[Music]
after discovering Elise had like Melissa
fallen into a coma elise's other niece
Imogen revealed that she too has the
ability to see the spirits and
volunteered to venture into the further
herself to hopefully rescue her
distressed family members she goes to KI
Face's Lair Beyond The Red Door the cell
block where he keeps all of his
prisoners and sees him slam Elise back
into captivity then he sets his sights
on Imaging although at least is able to
just telepathically free herself I'm not
sure why she didn't use this earlier
keface reappears with both nieces now in
captivity Elise offers to give herself
up bartering for the demon to let them
go but then he face just brutally slots
it across the room I actually kind of
appreciate this guy after being the one
demon in any of these 2010s Paranormal
horror movies that'll actually just
smack his enemies instead of aerating
him especially when you consider that
the last key was directed by Adam
robital a former paranormal activity
director I imagine that getting slapped
across the room is more painful too I
assume getting aerated feels something
like a good launch coaster it's shocking
but it's not really something that hurts
whereas getting smacked by Q face would
be a lot like riding Green Lantern first
flights you're definitely going to be
walking out of there with some bruises
and that's not the only damage that
keface dishes out he stabs Melissa in
the back causing her to ride then
convulse in the real world where she
begins to Flatline using some kind of
speed ability he tries to bum rush at
least but to her surprise her father's
ghost comes to her defense and key face
eliminates him with a single stab
causing him to just dissipate from the
further after all this time of being
afraid of keface and caving into his
evil demands I'm not really sure what
made Gerald finally stand up to his
captor if I had to guess he simply saw
this as his best opportunity to escape
but perhaps he also felt guilty after
seeing Elise take Mercy on him and
decided to actually help her out for
once however he's only a minor setback
for the powerful key phase whose Roar
knocks at least to the ground he tries
to do to her what he did to Melissa and
Imogen by locking for vocal cords but
Imogen realizes there's one thing she
can do without using her voice and
tosses at least the whistle this whistle
was once given to Christian as a way to
call his mother if he was ever afraid as
the demon goes for her heart Elise stabs
it in the face giving her a moment's
time to retrieve and sound the whistle
just as it had in her youth it summons
her mother who still lives in the
further as a spirit and fearlessly
confronts the monster is off my little
girl she faced charges but Mrs Rainier
issues an explosion of light from her
Lantern to send the creature blasting
off into the dark and if you look
closely the attack seems to burn right
through his body as well which seems to
suggest that the ancient keykeeper of
the do band Penitentiary is defeated
once and for all it makes sense that
this antagonist who represents the
trauma Elise incurred during her
childhood is destroyed shortly after the
demise of Gerald the one who physically
dished out that trauma and he's defeated
by Elisa's mom the one person who always
tried to stand up for release against
her father there's one thing I have to
address because I know people are going
to bring it up in the Blu-ray special
feature unlocking the five Keys
executive producer Bailey Conway anguits
offers a different account of keyface's
History
this is in elise's childhood home and
it's a big house on the prison property
her father was the assistant Warden of
the prison key face was a very old
prisoner who was wronged and that's why
he haunts this property this isn't part
of the movie itself so I don't really
consider it Canon and there are several
problems with this statement she says
keyface was an old prisoner who was
wrong there's no evidence of that in the
movie and he's specifically referred to
as a demon multiple times we know that
demons are non-human entities if you saw
my man who can't breathe video you may
remember that there was a similar mix up
regarding that character in Bailey
Conway inglewitz is the executive
producer while executive producer roles
can vary and how involved they are she's
essentially the person who funds the
movie so she may not be the definitive
Source on lore related stuff I do
appreciate that she has CZ in her name
though someone who is more definitive
regarding lore would be the writer Lee
wanal who clearly refers to both the man
who can't breathe and key face as demons
the demon really represents the trauma
that has affected Elise her whole life
and he face really does seem to affect
at least in a much more personal way
than even a more power powerful demon
like redface when dealing with redface
she certainly seems intimidated and
concerned but with keface it's personal
in one deleted scene the demon locks her
in this room in her house and she starts
crying and feels helpless turning her
into the little girl once locked in the
basement by her father that's why I
introduced Keith face the way I did at
the beginning of this video even if he
doesn't possess the raw power of redface
or the diverse subset of abilities is
the man who can't breathe it is key
faces psychological aspects that allowed
him to haunt and disturb the usually
stoic hero more than any other and if
you haven't seen my analysis of those
other Insidious Spirits check out that
playlist on the left to see the
histories of all this universe's
monsters if you love horror make sure
you subscribe to cz's world for new
Horrors every week ring the death bell
for all notifications and I will see you
in the next one assuming we both survive